thing is very important for a country
like India to have an accused of growth
agenda today India has got a population
of about 1.3 billion people but I think
we look at the mainstream people who are
the main economy are only about 300
million people the challenge for us is
to get the billion people back into the
economy and the only way to do that is
to and include and connect people to
rural India so I think technology is
going to play an important role
broadband is going to play a very
important role and the Government of
India is now trying to connect the
villages of India to broadband and that
is going to provide education health
care employment opportunities to more
and more people and that will make us a
big change so the way India progress is
the country